[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce set 8 nouvelles
formules plein d'infos de surprise n'est
ce pas mais william bonjour patrick
n'est pas de dire tout ce qu'il ya dans
cette division parce que j'ai
l'impression que tellement de choses que
via ce n'est même pas si on va y arriver
où je devrais aller on va essayer on va
on va commencer de suite par le sommaire
alors terre de jeu saint quentin en
yvelines célèbrent la journée olympique
sur deux jours les 22 et 23 juin 1200
élèves participent à des ateliers
sportifs et des animations au golf
national des athlètes fédérations sont
également présents ils ont à peine un
mois pour certains des bébés coyotes
loups arctiques ou encore aux renards
polaires sont nés au zoo de thoiry une
quinzaine de nouveaux pensionnaires que
nous avons pu rencontrer un énumérera
aussi de nombreuses anecdotes sur ces
naissances et enfin retour sur la fête
de la musique c'était hier mardi 21 juin
quelle a été l'ambiance dans les
yvelines est-ce que la fête était au
rendez vous réponse en fin d'émission
alors dans quelques instants on va
savoir ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité avec vos justes et une base
et b avant on en a cure tacchella
bonjour bonjour ça va bien ça va
travailler à la fête de la musique à
montigny c'est en ce sens hier vous êtes
musicien et l'or comme ils sont un peu
ficelle ils ont dit on va faire un jeu
avec lui on va
s'expliquer
on va faire un petit défi si vous
l'acceptez qu'elle taser ce jour là on
va vous donner sarko donc chacun en mots
et vous allez essayer de faire un
freestyle si c'est possible en fin
d'émission ok là dessus c'est dans une
improvisation c'est ça une invention va
dire à ces jeux
alors donc de rappeler bien les mots
donc je commence par les mieux notés jeu
mais j'ai pas de feuille alors
c'est bon je quitte ou double
alors moi et je commence par un bon mot
terry 78 hockey ma maison pas de souci
oui alors le sérieux journalistes
journalistes
l'échangé je dis maman d'un reportage
cueillette cueillette hockey
à moi j'étais alors il ya midget b et et
grigori cannelle et qui sont là parce
que vous allez vous parler de sport dans
quelques instants mais vous avez des
boues ou si vous savez celui d'hier de
bourdonner célia vous l'avez donné dans
le sommaire c'est un animal que j'aime
beaucoup qui est présent aux autres tu
aurais donc je veux dire un loup
arctique un
temps record sans fil ou encore honte
intégré vous voulez vous les connaissez
nous en veulent isoler
dernier puisque curtat portent haut les
couleurs les yvelines souvent dans ces
danses et chansons je lui donnais la
plus petite commune des yvelines c'est
le tartre godrans 36 habitants et où qui
est dans les yvelines
[Rires]
torchwood ont trouvé ça très beau c'est
vous allez bosser et puis enfin des
bijoux vous revenez avec grand plaisir
j'ai fait deux je vais me relever des
défis
super je pense
en attendant si vous voulez vous les
voulez savoir ce qu'il faut retenir à la
qpc parti alors ce qu'il faut retenir
dans l'actualité des yvelines aurore
bergé député de la 10e circonscription
des yvelines a été élu mardi matin
président du groupe renaissance à
l'assemblée nationale elle est la
première femme à diriger un groupe
majoritaire et puis emmanuel macron
s'exprimera ce soir à 20 heures un
discours qui intervient après la
consultation des différentes formations
politiques
dix sept victimes de viols et 141 une
d'agression sexuelle dénombre révélés
par une enquête interne à l'école
d'ingénieurs à agroparistech ce mardi un
questionnaire menée par cassis
associations étudiantes de lutte contre
les violences sexistes et sexuelles en
décembre dernier face à cette situation
alarmante l'établissement a saisi la
justice ce lundi si vous êtes passés
près d'achères aujourd'hui vous avez
peut-être reçu un sms d'alert ont
entendu des sirènes dont l'écho l'une
des communes alentour la préfecture des
yvelines tester ce mercredi 22 juin le
dispositif fr alerte à l'occasion d'un
exercice de sécurité civile organisée
sur le site du syndicat
interdépartemental d'assainissement de
l'agglomération parisienne il permettait
en fait de simuler un accident
industriel
et puis les soldes d'été sont lancés dès
aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 19 juillet un
rendez vous annuels marqués par une
période de forte inflation et en pouvoir
d'achat réduit une situation liée entre
autres au conflit ukrainien et à la
crise sanitaire côté loisirs la
traditionnelle fête des loges revient ce
vendredi 24 juin et ce jusqu'au 15 où
des centaines de milliers de visiteurs
sont attendus au coeur de la forêt de
saint germain en laye au programme un
manège pour les plus petits attractions
à sensations fortes ou encore la célèbre
allée des cuisines pour se restaurer et
puis en sport la journée les journées
olympiques et paralympiques elles se
tiennent donc ses 22 et 23 juin au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
1200 enfants attendus sur place jusqu'à
demain objectif mettre à l'honneur les
disciplines olympiques et leur valeur
initiation à la boxe au taekwondo à la
gymnastique ou encore au handball et
justement justin vous et bixente vous
êtes l du coup à cette journée olympique
et n'a pas fait pour les enfants
archives est bon
vous avez rencontré arnaud courtier qui
est donc c'est le directeur c'est simple
je dois un sport
et bains propose de vous deux vous
regarde de regarder ce reportage bonjour
à nos courtiers merci de nous recevoir
ici au practice du golf national pendant
deux jours vous allez donc recevoir
environ 1200 élèves pour les journées
les olympiques comment ça va s'articuler
ces deux jours lui a coûté nous
travaillons avec les établissements
scolaires de saint quentin en yvelines
de manière à ce qu'un maximum d'enfants
puissent venir pendant deux jours dont
un peu plus de six cent premiers jours
et la même chose de deux yens découvrir
différents sports grâce aux ateliers qui
nous entourent ici une quarantaine
d'ateliers avec évidemment des
animateurs sportifs qui leur permettent
de tester tous ces sports donc comme
vous l'avez dit 40 ateliers il ya des
sports connu comme le handball le rugby
par exemple d'autres sports plus
insolite c'est ça il ya plein de sports
le but c'est vraiment de leur donner
l'opportunité de découvrir donc
effectivement il ya du badminton il ya
du handball il ya
qu'est-ce qu'il ya plein de choses et du
tir à l'arc il ya du foot il ya du
trampoline il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et justement je crois que les
enfants sont ravis et je vous propose de
découvrir ce qu'il pense de ces journées
oui
on a fait par exemple du jonglage on a
fait du tennis on a fait du basket en
fauteuil et du hand en fauteuil roulant
sont très amusantes et les partager avec
des personnes qu'on connaît c'est encore
meilleurs seront là c'est la journée
bien en plus il ya un bouton relation
n'a fait la musculation
tennis de table et
on a fait vtt et rugby qu'on a fait la
muscu et voilà
on en mange à des spectacles et voilà en
ce moment en ce moment même la journée
se passe bien l'ultimate way et trucs là
où pour ceux qui ont pas de jambes du
coup il faisait un
bail qu'on avait
franchement elle fait des sports je les
connaissais mais j'en ai jamais pratiqué
de boxe jamais fait de la danse
comme de la danse urbaine comme on a
fait et c'était génial on a fait de la
boxe que je vous ai aimés et là on est
sur l'espace de gym c'est un sport que
j'aime bien et que je ferais chic en
dehors de l'école
arnaud comme nous avons vu les enfants
sont ravis c'était important dans
l'organisation des jeux olympiques de
2024 ici à saint quentin en yvelines de
parler aux jeunes oui c'est même s'il ya
de plus important parce que l'héritage
des jeux sur le territoire doit être
sociale sociétale le sport c'est bon
pour la santé et c'est aussi quelque
chose de merveilleux au niveau du lien
social les enfonce pose moins de
question que les adultes qui viennent
avec les copains ils mettent un short un
tee shirt qui font du sport ensemble
tous ensemble quelles que soient leurs
origines quelles que soient leurs
origines sociales religieuses dans le
pineau sera donc c'est essentiel et
surtout ça leur donne envie de continuer
à pratiquer et ça va faire d'eux des
supers spectateurs des jeux de palets
1024 d'autres acteurs aujourd'hui les
représentants des fédérations qui
interviennent sur tous ces ateliers eu
pareil c'est important pour eux ça leur
permet de de faire parler de leur
discipline peut être moins connu
exactement et ça leur permet
potentiellement de venir ici recruter
des membres de clubs sportifs
d'associations sportives donc c'est très
important parce que c'est finalement
tout l'écosystème du sport qui est
impliqué du sport associatif et ça c'est
très très important pour le
développement du sport sur notre
territoire et donc il ya plusieurs sites
olympiques sur 50 ans divine donc
pourquoi organiser ces journées ici au
golf national a pour deux raisons
principales la première vous avez vu
l'espace on a besoin de beaucoup d
espace et la deuxième c'est que la
fédération française de golf et philippe
il a tall directeur du golf national
nous prêtent très gentiment ce grand
practice et c'est un des rares endroits
où nous pouvons nous installer pour
avoir cette quarantaine d'ateliers
recevoir tous ses enfants au même moment
il ya le practice du coup qui a investi
comme le disait ça va même un peu plus
loin c'est c'est encore au delà du
practice to le goff et rennes n'ont
quand même pas tous veulent pas tout le
golf mais sur un terrain voisin
effectivement où on en a d'autres
ateliers sportifs du vélo entre autres
vous le savez les sports de saint
quentin en yvelines les sports
olympiques sont le cyclisme et le golf
donc il est important que ces deux
sports soient présents dans les ateliers
de découverte aujourd'hui et pour finir
je crois que vous faites participer
aussi les élèves à la fin par une flash
mob ou un flashmob oui exactement
c'était un bon moyen en fin de compte de
leur faire préparer cette journée de les
embarquer de les fédérer et d'avoir un
moment festif en fin de journée et
cotait merci beaucoup à nos courtiers
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous c'est
d'aujourd'hui permettent donc de aux
enfants de découvrir les sports et les
sports olympiques alors vous étiez
justine et vincente au golf national
qu'est-ce que vous on raconte un petit
peu comme ça l'ambiance ce qui vous a
surprise il vous à nous pour le coup on
était vraiment comme de grands enfants
je pense sur place à l'idée c'est comme
vous l'avait dit et comme on a entendu
arnaud courtier le dire c'était vraiment
de présenter et d'initier les enfants à
ces disciplines olympiques mais surtout
aussi aux valeurs ça c'était très
important pour eux donc découvrir les
valeurs et il y avait vraiment
énormément disciplines représentées on a
vu la gymnastique avait aussi de
l'escrimé avec du badminton handball il
y avait énormément de choses oui comme
dit je saigne beaucoup de disciplines
olympiques et aussi des disciplines
paralympiques de ski et c6 faut autant
de fauteuils et on a pu voir que les
enfants étaient vraiment ravi d'être là
il s'amusait beaucoup entre eux en plus
en classe entre autres c'était vraiment
une journée pour
d'apprentissage de nouveaux sports de
découvertes médicales ouais pour avoir
déjà couvert l'événement
c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il ya un
engouement qui commença à se monter la
valeur olympique qui voulait pas
forcément dire grand chose pour ces
jeunes commencent à appeler le comme son
sens et on parle souvent de la
génération 2024 c'est aussi eux qui vont
faire vivre ces jo et on sent que cet
engouement cet enthousiasme est en train
de monter progressivement et la mer est
une petite anecdote il ya les olivier
giroud champion olympique de handball
championne du monde andres à ne pas
confondre avec olivier giroud et je me
rappelle que les envolées
ils ont fait connaissance avec eux mêmes
un grand nom du sport et qui a été
champion olympique les footballeurs sur
plus connu que les routes d'alsace et
le tombé mais c'est vrai que c'est très
bien de faire découvrir et vous avez
raison de dire c'est au delà du sport il
ya aussi toutes ces valeurs qui sont
travaillées pendant le siège de 10 est
juste un à un en un mot c'est que là
certains enfants pour cela était
peut-être trop jeune mais le but
d'emmener les enfants vers 2024
l'échéance c'est que certains
participants ont peut-être en tant que
bénévole en fait aux jeux olympiques
étaient pas l'assurance que nous on
arrivait à 14 heures et il avait déjà
testé trois ou quatre sports chacun sait
donc pas contents et ses enfants ils
viennent d'où décollent de
basse et très bien et fort encore
l'année prochaine année l'année dernière
on avait été un peu on a fait des
émissions depuis là-bas on fera
peut-être l'année prochaine ça vaut le
coup parce que c'est vraiment un moment
très sympathique on continue avec le
sport au quotidien que l'espère justin
est d'ailleurs on va vous retrouver tous
les instants pour pour les infos dijon
merci et donc on continue on va parler
foot toi et moi collée vous puisque vous
aidera à gagner pour la première fois de
son histoire la coupe des yvelines et
bien on reçoit deux artisans de ce titre
c'est johan leslie bonjour bonjour c'est
lui et vous êtes pire d'un
[Rires]
petit pas seul parce qu'il ya vaut
d'abord félicitations et budget et qui
est absolument partout vous avez vu
je dirais pas supporters mais reporters
et donc que ça vous a fait quoi de
ramener cette coupe la fête était belle
et bah ouais très bonne c'était le
dernier match de la saison d'une saison
qui a été très longue on a gagné
quasiment toute la saison sauf au moins
bon moment en championnat et du coup il
nous fallait cette récompense c'est veut
dire l'homme
en championnat mais on était devant
quasiment tout le tout championnat on à
rester même 18 matches sans perdre
d'ailleurs des u match consécutif et on
a perdu on a perdu des points sur le
dernier mois et on perd le match le
match pour la montée qu'on ne se
retrouvaient là la dernière journée donc
coups durs et deux semaines à prendre
avait cette finale donc ça il fallait
gagner mais ça va se remobiliser mais on
a réussi à le faire et du coup c'était
une très belle fête dimanche puisqu'il
faisait beau il y avait nos familles nos
amis donc c'était vraiment vraiment bien
sûr cette coupe de france que tout le
monde connait revivre il y à des coûts
dans tous les départements c'est ça
alors il yad'autres les départements et
nous dans du coup dans les yvelines
c'est uniquement les équipes de niveau
départemental
donc on a à jouer pour toutes les
équipes du département est jamais arrivé
on a réussi à un doigt de champion pour
la première fois l'histoire du club donc
ouais c'est moi j'aime plaisir
et depuis chez vous on disait à vous
étiez présent tesco peut-être vous faire
un petit résumé oui bien déjà la finale
avait lieu au stade du gymnase jules
ladoumègue à montils bretenoux le match
donc opposer le voisin football club à
l'équipe réserve de trappes sur le
papier les favoris de la rencontre elle
aurait pu pourtant échappé aux huit
chinois en première mi-temps beaucoup
d'occasions manquées sanctionnée par un
but contre le cours du jeu mais les
vicinaux à pousse jusqu'à l'égalisation
libératrice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme on peut le voir y avait du monde
en tribune pas mal d'ambiance sur le
terrain vous l'avez ressenti comment
l'ambiance
non c'était
un peu de stress et que c'était plutôt
pour travailler des deux côtés il y
avait du monde comme c'était à montigny
sur internet c'était vraiment proche des
deux villes donc beaucoup de monde ça
c'était une trame c'est une très belle
fête honnêtement ça s'est vraiment bien
passé sur le terrain aucun problème est
énoncé ça fait plaisir de jouer contre
devant parlons beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes c'est stimulant de jouer en
deuxième mi temps elles étaient plutôt
hachée on peut le dire le sentiment
était plutôt étrange entre ému les
réactions sont faites à des coups de
pied arrêtés aucune des deux équipes
n'est parvenue à prendre le dessus
malgré la domination en possession de
balle notamment deux voisins on
s'achemine logiquement jusqu'à la
fatidique séance des tirs au but le
gardien de trappes en art est un mets
johan pierre le vôtre en arrête deux
dont un sur la barre et un arrêt ou
regarde d'ailleurs l'ultime penalty qui
a scellé le sort du match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'imagine qu'il a fallu garder la tête
froide
moussavi avant qu'ils allaient tirer
était décidé avant on les connaît donc
ils sont déterminés à vent balayant
petits changements parce que navin qui
était un peu blessé du coup on s'est
réajusté mais non ils prennent leurs
responsabilités ils savent eux et ça
toujours en avant ses leviers et nous
avons confiance dans notre gardien
totalement en bas en plus de six ans
s'était qualifié au tour précédent aux
tirs au but également donc s'était passé
en notre faveur ça va continuer tant
mieux pour le gagnant coupe de france
aux tirs au but c'est un début de saison
contre une régionale 2 alors vous êtes
des habitués de ces spéciales
et ouais et il en a même arrêté trois
puisque celui qu'il arrête le plus
décisif il a été retiré il a été libéré
et à deux fois ça nous a fait peur à ce
moment là bas se faire retirer c'est
toujours que tu sois plus ce sont bien
les serait d'ailleurs un peu
arbitres tient parce qu'il est trop
avancée s'est fait retirer on n'a pas
très bien compris en plus il ya eu un
moment de flottement en tribunes
puisqu'il a pris un carton jaune
derrière
soi parce que le après son arrêt
du 10 ans même s'il tire quatre fois
j'arrête 4
[Rires]
c'est bien on a en a parmi nous on a la
chance d'avoir des rites des cavaliers
qui donne un excédent jour me dise pas
oui qui est aussi gardien de but dans la
1 et c'est vrai que c'est on se dit
toujours que c'est quoi l'état d'esprit
d'un gardien de but pour la séance de
tirs au but après tout il ya rien à
perdre il n'y a rien à perdre après
c'est de faire le vide dans sa tête il
ya plusieurs techniques alors ya des
gardiens qui vont anticiper choisir un
côté d'autres qui vont réagir c'est vrai
qu'avec les nouvelles règles et
notamment ce qui a été mise à jour par
par les fédérations maintenant le
gardien n'a plus le droit de quitter sa
ligne doit avoir les deux pieds sur sa
ligne donc c'est difficile de partir au
moment de la frappe moi mon sens je
pense qu'il faut toujours choisir un
côté je sais pas si votre gardien fait
ce choix là mais les clients dont la
frappe on est mort après il ya toujours
des signes moi j'ai ma petite technique
que je vais pas vivre aimer
regard du joueur l'un peut positionner
le haut parleur au ballon le pied du
tireur c'est un peu tard pour savoir
s'ils ouvrent si le ferme ça peut être
aussi une technique qui soit aussi
droitier ou gaucher vrai aussi parfois
des attitudes différentes face au ballon
après chacun chaque gardien sa technique
ya pas deux il n'y a pas de miracle il
n'y a pas de technique et venir avec moi
est ce que le foot amateur il n'y a rien
de plus en plus de deux joueurs qui tire
à peu à la nema
en s'arrêtant un peu ouais voilà savons
ce qui marche chez les pros on essaye de
le faire et ça les lycées à mon avis le
meilleur terreau penalty mois que ces
abus mais non mais c'est surtout chez
les jeunes chez les jeunes c'est
beaucoup il sera bien parce que
et du coup ça se reproduit darche et
adultes ensuite mais bon tout cas bravo
saison très fier pour nouer et puis il
faut tenir le titre l'année prochaine
rien on essaie on ira si tu voulais
prochaine pour fêter le titre avec vous
et désireux de les monter les prochaines
donc les doubles
bravo
alors on va parler rencontre d'une
association de renommer les restos du
coeur organisent samedi 25 juin et pour
la première fois une journée portes
ouvertes dans tous les centres d'accueil
de france alors bien sûr les yvelines
n'y échappe à une quinzaine de sites
accueilleront tous ceux qui souhaitent
avoir des informations regardez ce
reportage
c'est une première les restos du coeur
organisent leurs premières portes
ouvertes samedi 25 juin dans toute la
france et les yvelines participent que
ce soit pour récolter des informations
sur l'aide alimentaire ou bien pour
s'engager au sein de l'association les
bénévoles seront là pour répondre à
toutes les questions c'est vraiment une
première problème pour les restos du
coeur
d'une façon générale donc dans toute la
france
pourquoi pourquoi la journée portes
ouvertes c'est que jusqu'à ce jour les
raisons sont surtout connus
en termes de communication extérieure
surtout par le concert des et
la collecte nationale donc ces deux
temps forts qui ont qu'il avait lieu en
début d'année et là l'idée de
l'association nationale c'est de
relancer un peu l'image des restos alors
que la précarité s'aggrave et que les
prix augmentent ces journées portes
ouvertes sont l'occasion pour les restos
du coeur d'aller à la rencontre de ceux
qui n'osent pas pousser les portes des
centres d'accueil au total une quinzaine
de sites seront ouverts le matin ou
l'après midi dont le chantier
d'insertion aux clayes-sous-bois le
premier travail c'est la socialisation
socialisation et que lorsqu'on a levé
tous ces obstacles tous ces blocages on
peut ensuite aller vers la recherche
d'emploi donc il ya des bénévoles pour
chaque bénéficiaire lien bénévoles qui
l'accompagnent dans sa recherche
d'emploi dans l'élaboration de son
projet professionnel souvent méconnus du
public l'association ne se charge pas
seulement de faire de l'aide alimentaire
elle s'engage également dans
l'accompagnement au numérique juridique
ou même dans l'aide au logement cette
journée est ouverte à tous et se
poursuivra par le bal des restos animées
par des dj
est d'ailleurs un nouveau centre va être
inauguré à magnanville mercredi 29 juin
c'est le 26e des civils alors céline
charme nous a rejoint bordeaux on va
parler avec vous dans le but magnifique
vous exposer un événement dimanche c'est
le désert de retz est exactement mais on
va commencer d'abord avec nicolas landry
bonsoir si vous êtes notre journaliste
qui prend la route ont tous les deux
économique est fait et je vais ramener
la route voilà je vais vous parler de ça
en fait ça s'est mis un échantillon de
routes ou de trottoir je voulais sans
regarder toucher et donc la spécificité
de cet échantillon et de déroute qui
sont fabriqués comme ça et bien c'est
qu'elles sont fabriquées avec de la
matière végétale ces liens demeurent des
pas de danse est pas une période facile
vous allez avoir de problème de
dentition on va prendre tout de suite la
direction du colas richert church center
c'est le centre de recherche et de
développement de l'entreprise colas qui
est basée à manille enfin colas je le
rappelle c'est la filiale du groupe
bouygues spécialisée dans la conception
et l'entretien des infrastructures de
transport donc ils fabriquent des routes
ils sont aussi sur les rails et patrick
jacques de dixmude et bien nous nous
sommes rendus sur place nous avons
visité les laboratoires où sont
développés les innovations destinées au
goût du futur et regardez j'ai revêtu la
tenue d'un scientifique blues et
lunettes de protection regarder ça
[Musique]
dehors du terrain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon là ça y est la junior avec vous
est-ce que
musique c'est pas sorcier
donc bon scientifique crédible non
moi je pense que
en fait je pense que vous travaillez
chez colas passait pas bien avait 68 ans
la blouse ne fait pas le moine ou
l'habit ne fait pas le scientifique un
choisissez celles que vous voulez plus
sérieusement alors nous avons donc
parler d'une innovation qui permet de
fabriquer des routes à partir d'un liant
d'origine végétale c'est ceci c'est ce
que j'ai dans la main donc c'est un lien
en fait ce qui permet de rassembler tous
les caillols on a vu sur l'échantillon
est en fait ça remplace le pétrole par
rapport au bitume et on écoute tout de
suite un myriam des roches qui est chef
de projet chimie verte au sein du groupe
kohl svg comme cet enrobé clair qui est
fabriqué à partir d'un liant d'origine
végétale donc ce lien il est fabriqué
dans le sud de la france et il est
constitué de résine issus du pain et
d'huile obtenu à partir d'oléagineux on
va venir travailler à une température
assez modérée on va chauffer l'huile on
va y ajouter de la résine et on obtient
donc ce lien c'est un lien en clair donc
qui permet de mettre en valeur la teinte
naturelle des granulats et c'est ce qui
nous permet d'accéder donc à ce type de
robes et donc des enrobés clair comme
celui ci ou celui là après vous
choisissez les granulats les cailloux en
fonction de ce que vous voulez obtenir
comme comme esthétique et donc on peut
les utiliser dans des applications type
piste cyclable zone piétonne ou centres
urbains on peut circuler alors ce type
d'échantillon le trouve déjà déjà à
manille des hameaux puisqu'ils l'ont
testé et il est déjà en place sur leur
site on le trouvait en france ou dans le
monde et cette innovation permet aussi
de participer à réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre on écoute de
nouveaux myriam des roches l'analyse de
cycle de vie du vg cole a montré que sa
composition spécifique en faire un puits
de carbone donc il bien absorbées le
carbone qui est dans l'atmosphère lors
de la photosynthèse et on a donc un
puits de carbone et c'est à comparer
alors oui au bitume c'est sûr mais sur
des applications esthétique vous avez
beaucoup rencontrer les bétons
désactivés où les pavages qui représente
une empreinte carbone assez élevé à
cause de l'emploi du ciment est donc là
avec nos matières végétales on a un vrai
gain en terme de co2 alors voilà pour
cette innovation mais sachez qu'il ya
d'autres innovations qui sont en
développement au sein du colosse
ricerche center de magny les hameaux une
autre innovation qu'on découvrira
notamment vendredi dans le numéro du sky
et qu on découvrira au wat fouet en fait
c'est une route où il ya des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui seront recrutés et
qui permettent alors non pas de
recharger les voitures mais d'alimenter
en énergie électrique les
infrastructures qui sont autour voilà
c'est bien parce que souvent on parle de
la transition écologique sans savoir ce
que c'est et là on est en plein vol à de
très concret qu'est ce que fait une
entreprise spécialisée dans un domaine
industrielles comme les infrastructures
comme en effet sa transition vers des
solutions ou des produits qui sont plus
environnementalement parlant qui est
responsable dit m non mais c'est quand
même très très important c'est très bien
non mais c'est vrai que non parce que je
vais dire simplement c'est vrai que
parfois on a des mots comme ça d'un peu
théorie et là on voit concrètement la
tristesse que je connais est ce que font
les entreprises pour cette transition ex
audi merci beaucoup nicolas landry les
plaisirs c'est très bien moi je ne dis
rien
on va partir maintenant à chambourcy
avec vous céline donc un événement
culturel un port important aura lieu
dimanche 26 juin donc la ville de
chambourcy va accueillir leurs caisses
de la garde républicaine pour un concert
exceptionnel le tout dans un lieu
atypique qui on peut dire eh oui est ce
que vous connaissez le désert de red ce
oui moi je l'avais intéresse manger
après c'est un lieu magnifique
formidable façon pour cela
les olympiques et n'y a pas de saab à
l'horizon ce n'est pas
tout c'est un parc fabrique
anglo-chinois créé au xviiie siècle
siècle des lumières par françois-henri
racines de montville infortunés et
passionné de botanique
le parc se situe du coup dans la petite
commune de chambourcy en bordure nord de
la forêt de marly et sa 17 hectares sur
les 39 d'origine sont accessibles
aujourd'hui au public alors pourquoi le
nom désert alors parce que c'est un lieu
isolé
qui se veut espace de rêveries de
réflexion quelques mots de pierre
morange le maire de chambourcy sur ce
jardin et son propriétaire cet homme
poursuivait un objectif très précis
c'est à dire celui de créer un micro
comme une sorte de reproduction du monde
raison pour laquelle il a fait à portée
d essence dans tous les continents et il
y à l'intérieur de cet espace de
quelques 40 hectares il n'y a fait
ériger des fabriques qui représentent
chacune d'entre elles une civilisation
qui a marqué l'histoire de l'humanité et
au cours de votre balade là bas vous
pourrez donc apercevoir une dizaine de
petites constructions qu'on appelle donc
des fabriques elles sont d'inspiration
chinoise orientale ou antiques par
exemple une église gothique en ruines
une colonne détruites ou encore une
glacière en forme de pyramide l'idée
c'est d'avoir un petit parcours
initiatique qui évoque différentes
cultures et courants de pensée si ça
s'était même de sao son rêve c'était de
regrouper toutes les cultures en un seul
lieu c'était ça c'est une utopie
absolument formidable et si vous nous
emparer en plus c'est parce qu'il ya un
événement important qui va dérouler et
oui exactement concert exceptionnel de
l' orchestre de la garde républicaine
donc je pense que ça
renommée n'est plus à faire créé en 1848
c'est un élément de la gendarmerie
nationale composée en tout 220 musiciens
professionnels issus de conservatoires
nationaux de lyon et de paris donc
orchestre d'harmonie symphonique ou
encore la corde ils sont en mesure
d'interpréter tout le répertoire musical
classique du xviie siècle jusqu'à nos
jours alors ils jouent dans des dîners
officiels à l'elysée des commémorations
mais aussi par exemple des festivals ou
dans les salles de concert et ce
dimanche ils seront donc au jardin de ré
au désert de ritz et cet orchestre va
prendre place dans ce lieu magnifique
monsieur le maire nous en dit un petit
peu plus de la fin du livre vi ème
siècle qui voulant à être être créé et
écrit la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et donc finalement la garde
républicaine qui est l'emblème musicale
de la nation et aussi les valeurs de la
république il y avait un pas qu'il
fallait créer franchir et il fallait
bien que ça soit au désert de red ce
afin que le 18e et 21e siècles on en
trouve la traduction c'est aussi une
occasion de souligner l'universalité la
pensée française et la capacité à se
réunir autour et au sein des valeurs de
la république et alors céline qu'est ce
que on pourra écouter alors vous pouvez
écouter des musiques composées par
beethoven visée ou encore piccini et
laurenti clin d'oeil à un acteur connu
on va écouter un petit extrait pour voir
si vous avez la plaque avant ça
oui
[Musique]
c'est fini c'est la mesure qui dans un
film original dans six le professionnel
exact
bbc donc effectivement et c'est pas
énorme morricone chez soi et je crois
que la garde républicaine a joué cette
terre le jour des obsèques le servage
aux invalides c'était ça c'était jean
paul belmondo et du coup ils vont
rejouer ce morceau là dimanche mais
c'est bien comme des torts après la
belgique tadjiks et bien faire ça c'est
une très belle idée d'élimination un
classique du cinéma français
est donc le concert et dimanche 26 juin
donc ce dimanche à 15h30 il est gratuit
pour les habitants de chambourcy et au
prix de 30 euros pour les autres la
réservation les réservations se font par
mail et donc dépêchez-vous pour avoir
vos places c'est un événement qui est
assez prisé mais on y sera c'était
vois pas ce que ça vaut quand même le
coup d'aller voir ça serait dommage de
passer à côté de cet événement
exactement
merci beaucoup merci vous aviez dit que
vous allez y aller vous a peut-être bien
parce que
ça me tape très bien imaginer
beaucoup à redire
alors moi j'adore le premier là bas
c'est super avant de vous promener
peut-être que vous pourriez nous
rappeler ce qu'il faut est-ce que j'ai
fallait vous emmener tout de suite
alors ce qui peut retenir dans
l'actualité dans les yvelines laurent
berger député de la 10e circonscription
des yvelines a été lue mardi matin
président du groupe renaissance à
l'assemblée nationale elle est la
première femme à diriger un groupe
majoritaire et puis emmanuel macron
s'exprimera ce soir à 20 heures un
discours qui intervient après la
consultation des différentes formations
politiques
dix sept victimes de viols et 140 et une
d'agression sexuelle dénombre révélés
par une enquête interne à l'école
d'ingénieurs agro paris tech ce mardi un
questionnaire menée par cassis
associations étudiantes de lutte contre
les violences sexistes et sexuelles en
décembre dernier face à cette situation
alarmante l'établissement à segi a saisi
la juge ce lundi si vous êtes passé près
d'un cher aujourd'hui vous avez
peut-être reçu un sms dallaire tout
entendu des sirènes dans les communes
alentour la préfecture des yvelines
tester ce mercredi 22 juin le dispositif
fr alerte c'était à l'occasion d'un
exercice de sécurité civile organisée
sur le site du syndicat
interdépartemental d'assainissement de
l'agglomération parisienne il permettait
de simuler un accident industriel
les soldes d'été sont lancés dès
aujourd'hui et ce jusqu'au 19 juillet un
rendez vous annuel marqué à part une
période de forte d'un de forte inflation
et un pouvoir d'achat réduit une
situation liée entre autres au conflit
au kenya et à la crise sanitaire et puis
côté loisirs la traditionnelle fête des
loges revient ce vendredi 24 juin et ce
jusqu'au 15 où des centaines de milliers
de visiteurs sont attendus au coeur de
la forêt de saint germain en laye au
programme manège pour les plus petits
attractions à sensations fortes ou
encore la célèbre allée des cuisines
pour se restaurer et puis enfin en sport
les journées olympiques et paralympiques
se tiennent ces 22 et 23 juin au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
1200 enfants attendus sur place jusqu'à
demain objectif mettre à l'honneur les
disciplines olympiques et leur valeur
initiation à la boxe au taekwondo à la
gymnastique ou encore au hand-ball on
verra bien de la patrie soudain vous
allez tester non peut-être d'être
accessible qui reste et
il ya tous ces nouveaux manèges moi
j'aimerais bien voir commencer et on va
les détester la semaine prochaine aux
mineurs non le rendez vous est pris on
va tester avec d'euros et sivori la
division vous nous racontez
moi j'attends la photonique et non comme
ça
sur le gros salaires est juste une
question indiscrète à vous poser deux ne
permet tait
est ce que vous aimez les fruits rouges
non
salée pour lesquels n'ont pas sévi que
les cerises et récemment maintenant
c'est plutôt les fraises je crois
figurent des mortiers par bêtise d'une
ferme ça sert l'école qui s'appelle la
ferme de gally bien sûr reconnaît très
connu par ailleurs une année
exceptionnelle pour les pour les
groseilles pour les caciques pour les
fraises qui veut pas été le cas l'un des
derniers à cause des intempéries mars
est allé c'était formidable et julien
leroy s'est rendu sur place exactement
pour regarder abus on va en parler après
on regarde le reportage de julien leroy
une année d'exception pour les fruits
rouges à la ferme de gally de
saint-cyr-l'ecole groseilles cassis
fraises ou encore griotte ce week end de
nombreuses familles se sont retrouvées
pour profiter d'une journée ensoleillée
tout en savourant les plaisirs de la
nature est très agréable parce que ça
allie une balade dans la nature
en même temps le plaisir d'avoir des
fruits et des légumes qui sont locales
de saison rien dit ce n'est qu'il ya des
demoiselles des frais ouais j'ai manqué
le temps sec et doux depuis la fin de
l'hiver a permis des récoltes longue et
constante sur l'ensemble des fruits
rouges on a une année qui a été
relativement chaude avec un printemps
des températures qui ont été assez élevé
dès le mois de février ce qui a permis
une croissance et un mentir des boutons
floraux à la différence de l'année
dernière où il ya eu des gros jet li na
mais très pluvieuse l'occasion pour lés
parents de sensibiliser leurs enfants au
respect de la nature et au plaisir des
préparations maison à les enseignants
elle va rentrer en ce2 donc on lui dit
bien de respecter la nature c'est très
important et puis on lui fait découvrir
également les différentes sortes de
fruits et de fleurs on cache surtout des
fraises pour faire des confitures ss par
une très belle année qui devrait durer
jusqu'à début octobre pour les myrtilles
ou encore les cassis cet été environ
2000 personnes sont attendues chaque
week end à la ferme de gally
alors après ce reportage qui nous a mis
l'eau à la bouche
michaelides bonjour
on va continuer de parler à des fermes
de gally exactement on a vu dans ce
reportage l'espace cueillette de la
ferme de gally et il nous sommes avec
bono gansel le responsable communication
des fermes de gally alors bruno qu'est
ce qu'il ya sur cette table basse et des
fruits des fruits et légumes que j'ai
accueilli ce matin pour vous ce matin ce
matin ce matin la fage ont peu goûté
il ya des fruits rouges et une pomme de
terre
il ya des fruits rouges framboise et de
la myrtille mais il ya également plein
de légumes de ricoh donner un corps
jette des tomates
des tomates on assume
toutes ses toutes premières toutes
premières escales notammment problème
c'est qu'on mange des choses pas forcée
au ski de match voir exactement d'où
l'intérêt la ferme de gally où nous tous
tous en pleine terre donc on suit
vraiment le rythme des saisies des
toutes premières tomates et on va le
plein coeur de la saison va commencer
d'ici une quinzaine de jours la partie
du willis 15 juillet ou en arrivant donc
plein boom de la saison de la tomate
mais les les alerter de pommes de terre
nouvelles nouvelles séries ce n'est pas
d'hier que je sais que j'ai déterré ce
matin par les premiers en règle au bon
lait salade on en a depuis un certain
temps on vient de passer le grand pic
delà de la fraise alors on va avoir
maintenant de la fraise remontantes
jusque septembre octobre voire fin
octobre c'est si la météo assez clémente
donc on va avoir une grande diversité de
productions là jusqu'à l'automne eric le
nom dans ce moment il n'y a pas mal de
m'en donner ça ç'a bien fonctionné on a
la chance d'avoir une année qui qui se
déroule bien avec un jeune qui n'a pas
fait de dégâts cette année contrairement
aux années précédentes qui nous ont
beaucoup pénalisé les années précédentes
sur de la pomme donc on
on espère avoir une belle production
pommery dont il ya une belle production
et pas mal de monde quand une corde
hormis qu'alibaba le monde peut venir
cueillir chez vous ça voilà le principe
c'est tout simple l'accès libre à la
cueillette on rentre dans les champs les
parcelles sont indiqués avec des petites
flèches avec le nom des montants
généralement une brouette a aussi le
projet sur d'habitude
chez nous y'a pas de caddies
effectivement on prend sa brouette et
puis après on se promène dans les champs
et on va chercher qui des salades des
tomates des courgettes c'était bien
parce que c'est la foi c'est le bon
travail et c'est éducatif aussi pour les
eaux sombres non oui il ya encore un peu
comment ça vous ils vont être épais
d'allinges et quelle est leur a dit
c'est pas donné à tout le monde de
savoir que sa cause dans la terre n'est
pas vu alors que la tomate
poussant surface alors que le radi a un
côté rouge et la tomate aussi donc oui
pour les enfants il ya beaucoup
d'ailleurs de d'enfants qui sont
accompagnées souvent avec les mamans le
mercredi et et puis avec les la famille
en général de le week-end et qui
viennent faire leurs récoltes et ce qui
est amusant avec les enfants c'est que
il n'aime pas forcément tous les légumes
verts 1 les épinards ou les courgettes
quand ils sont partis jeudi que
le légume il a une autre histoire
s'inspire des yeux on prépare avec eux
est passé manger beaucoup plus
facilement et il ya également aussi des
activités il n'y a pas que la cueillette
aux fermes de gally il y aura également
les labyrinthes en sept épées haches
c'est ça que ça a commencé depuis fermé
les labyrinthes ont alors commencé il ya
un mois et demi à peu près on renouvelle
les thématiques cette année on est
reparti sur des nouveaux labyrinthes
autour des petites poules qui est une bd
à destination des enfants on a fait un
autre labyrinthe sur le thème du roman
de renart on a un labyrinthe sur les
tracteurs parce que le lien avec
l'agriculture nous est très cher donc on
a quatre 4 à labyrinthe avec des
nocturnes qui vont avoir lieu les
samedis les samedis de juillet puis
après ceux de septembre où on accueille
le public à partir de 19 heures jusqu'à
22h 22h30 dans une ambiance avec des
barbecues qui sont allumés les gens
viennent avec avec leurs grillades il ya
de la musique folklorique et puis on
faut pas oublier sa longue de pages pour
aller se
sont de nouveau elle a bien suivi et
dernière les thématiques
les thématiques sont nouvellement
dernier il y avait un labyrinthe sur les
illusions d'optique cette année on a on
a utilisé cet espace pour faire un
labyrinthe sur le roman de renart il y
avait un labyrinthe sur les légumes
cette année on a fait une thématique
autour des petites bêtes des insectes
noqui on se renouvelle et chaque année
c'est le travail de l'hiver la ferme de
gally dans les yvelines ça a été une des
premières françaises et cueillette on a
été une des premières fermes
à ouvrir nos champs à grand public
puisque l'accueil est ouvert aux 83 donc
pourquoi ça a commencé quelles étaient
les motivations parce qu'on est
agriculteur on agriculteurs dans l'âme
et on veut à travers tous nos métiers
faire découvrir ce
métier d'agriculteur leurs liens qui
qu'on a tous inscrits on monte à une ou
deux générations on a tous un ancêtre
qui est agriculteur sauf que le lien
avec le tonton le papy ils se disent en
plus en plus avec ça n'existe pas que
dans les supermarchés l'exacte ce que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la
saisonnalité des productions de saison
nous c'est notre c'est notre combat à
manger des framboises au mois de
décembre celio on peut le comprendre
mais pas chez nous bien mais c'est vous
parlais tout à l'heure de de l'écologie
va aider l voilà aussi une écologie
concrètes et puis en termes de de
traçabilité on peut pas faire mieux
puisque c'est le client qui vient le
chercher dans les champs on sait d'où ça
vient nos équipes de d'agriculteurs de
production sont dans les champs en même
temps que les
les gens sont en train de cueillir donc
on voit ce qui se passe et en pratique
on fait ça cette petite cueillette comme
ça et puis on passe à la caisse on
est en fait le tour de ce que vous les
ramasser puis après aux fonctions au
poids - l'unité puisqu'il ya dix ans
pendant que des fleurs qui sont vendus
au poids ou des flaques sont vendus à
lattes et ben spies et c'est légèrement
moins cher on me l'avait dit une fois
qu'en magasin légèrement sa dépendent
n'avait pas ça dépend des produits des
premiers comme comme la laframboise là
c'est très très nettement moins cher on
doit être à moins de huit euros le kilo
je suis une astuce en relatant ces temps
compliqués on les a goûté jose dur que
vous en trouverez peut-être pas des
comme ça nous
aide pas voulu mettre trop proche de
vous
et l'a23 sont partis depuis tout à
l'heure face à la tomate
le kg s'est pas réduit à 2,3 kg
chacun
entière
et voulait faire avec les tomates venait
au 15 juillet 20 juillet vous en prenez
une brouette 30 kg et puis vous pourrez
faire vos retours de tomates pour tout
l'hiver si vous voulez faire de la
confiture de framboises venez tout de
suite vous en ramasser 10 kg ce week end
et puis dimanche après midi vous faites
vos pots de confiture pour la partie
quand c'est fini c'est fini vous
refermez la parcelle voilà comme c'est
quand c'est fini comme vous dites c'est
fini quand il y en a plus nous ça pousse
dans nos champs sur nos plans une fois
que la cueillette et lieu alors des
produits comme la myrtille la cds
produits qui toutes les toutes les baies
n'arrive pas à maturité en même temps
sur un pied il y en a quelques-uns qui
deviennent bleues on les ramasse si on
repasse 8-10 jours après il y en a
d'autres qui vont avoir mûri donc là la
production va s'étaler dans le temps
est-ce que j'ai le sentiment que les
gens avaient besoin d'être se
reconnecter à la terre après ce qu'on a
vécu les confinements ces deux ans de
pandémie ce que vous avez senti qu est
peut-être ce besoin de se reconnecter à
la terre oui on a ressenti de manière
très évidente on a tous été contraint de
vous voyez du télétravail de rester chez
soi
et ce lien avec la nature était était
nécessaire et important et il ya d'une
part la volonté de se retourner en
extérieur faire des activités et puis il
ya de plus en plus une prise de
conscience de la saisonnalité de
l'écologie et manger en circuits courts
et manger des produits de saison sont
des gestes tout simples mais qui sont
efficaces efficients exigences plus en
plus conscience merci beaucoup moins de
monde venu merci et bravo pour ces
produits on a juste envie d'aller
merci merci beaucoup on va passer à
présent un autre instant mignonneries
cantatrice très bien mais oui parce que
on a parlé de louveteaux des renardeaux
des bébés coyote ou encore des bebig
nous un plaisir d'animaux rares sont
venus au monde au printemps au zoo de
thoiry et mathilde franco est allé les
voir en tout cas
2022 une année assez particulière pour
le zoo safari de thoiry les soigneurs
ont assisté cet hiver et au printemps à
la naissance de plusieurs espèces rares
en cette période de printemps on a eu
pas mal de naissance dernièrement sur le
parc on a eu particulièrement beaucoup
de qualités cet hiver déjà ça a commencé
avec les chiens des buissons et les
loups à crinière et ensuite au printemps
on a eu les coyotes les renards polaires
et les loups arctiques avec quatre
louveteaux sept bébés coyotes et 8
renardeau au niveau des canidés c'est
une année spéciale ces naissances se
font de manière totalement naturelle et
parfois même spontanée même si les
soigneurs détecte des signes avant
coureurs comme l'éloignement de la
femelle ou le fait qu'elles creusent un
terrier la femelle a creusé à lui même
son propre terrier à l'intérieur du parc
dans son enclos la femme et le couple de
loups arctiques et sont en liberté du
coup vraiment on les laisse faire au
niveau de la reproduction de leur
comportement naturel donc la femelle à
creuser son propre père y est elle est
allée mettre bas donc courant mai et
puis quelques semaines plus tard les
psys ont commencé à sortir de là de la
tanière ces nouvelles venues au monde
permet également de sauvegarder des
espèces qui sont menacées ou en voie de
disparition un début de départ que c'est
effectivement la conservation c'est le
principe d'avoir en fait les populations
captives de secours au cas où
effectivement les populations sauvages
venait à trop décroître voire à
disparaître en particulier on est devant
les oryx d'aravis une ex ps qui dans les
années 70 avait complètement disparu du
milieu naturel n'en restait plus que
dans les paroles et grâce aux efforts
justement de différents parcs qui ont pu
faire de la reproduction avisés de
réintroduction n'a plus réintroduire des
individus dans leur milieu naturel et
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs milliers
d'individus dorique ceux d'arabie seuls
trois parcs zoologiques en europe
accueille des coyotes c'est donc une
véritable fierté pour touahri d'avoir eu
une portée de sept bébés pareil pour les
loups arctiques cela faisait deux ans
que le mâle et la femelle se tourner
autour la porte est de 4,9 tout
représente donc un accomplissement pour
les soigneurs
[Musique]
et du coup on vous retrouve un plateau
mathilde de bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue
sur patrimoine soirée et bravo pour ce
sujet c'est vrai que ça fait rêver ça va
un peu hors du temps ce matin là vous
vraiment travailler en fait aujourd'hui
il y ait eu beaucoup en essence on a vu
un dans le reportage est donc la
reproduction et les naissances est ce
qu'elles se font de manière naturelle
oui c'est totalement naturel en tout cas
pour ces canidés là en fait ben la maman
dès qu'elle a commencé à sentir qu'elle
est qu'elle allait avoir des petits eh
ben elle a commencé à creuser son
terrier et puis pareil en fait les bébés
ne sont pas du tout approché son nez en
mai et aucun soigneur aucun vétérinaire
n'a jamais les a approchés encore alors
bientôt ils vont savoir si c'est des
femelles ou des mal parce qu'ils veulent
non ils savent pas encore il s'est fait
que j'ai vraiment eu beaucoup de chance
de les voir aujourd'hui et donc qu'ils
vont faire un premier état de santé
général pour voir si tout va bien et si
c'est le cas ils ne seront plus du tout
accroché par le ssh cela génère
peut-être des comportements naturels oui
oui parce que ce matin en fait quand on
est rentrés dans leur territoire y avait
un ours qui essayait de pas très sûre
sur leur terrain et donc en fait les
parents et ils voulaient à tout prix
repoussé l'ours pour protéger
alors que
exactement comme dans la nature donc
vraiment ça génère des comportements
naturels et donc ces nouvelles
naissances et ce qu'elles permettent de
faire peut-être perdurer des espèces en
voie de disparition
exactement c'est ce que mme expliqué
anne sophie magnan qu'on a vu dans le
reportage en fait aussi au niveau de
l'europe il va y avoir un coordinateur
pour chaque espèce qui va sélectionner
des couples pour faire une meilleure
génétique possible et du coup ça a
permis de sauver certaines espèces comme
les oryx d'arabie qu'on a vu dans le
sujet et je crois qu'on a vu au moment
dé nous sembla vous trompe peut-être des
renards noir oui tout à fait ça oui
c'est des renards polaires est en fait
leur pelage change en fonction des
saisons alors l'été comme on a vu et
sont plutôt brun foncé et l'hiver et se
camouflent donc ils sont plutôt parce
que
oui on viendra vous en avez des
anecdotes
si j'aime passionnant
vous avez envie de rester à rome c'est
pas mal quand même enfin une petite
boîte avec les fruits
et
après le
oui on va peut-être chanter on va
chanter on va pas changer un peu de
sujet on va parler musique merci
beaucoup merci qu'on m'a dit
alors donc depuis 1982 elles rythment
nos salles cistes d'été hier c'était la
quarantième année de la série
d'exercices saucisse de deux ans et sa
précieuse
et donc un disque
est donc vicente vous vous êtes rendu à
versailles pour voir si elle était elle
était célébrée en bonne et due forme on
va pouvoir voir ce reportage on en parle
juste après
c'est un des points centraux de la fête
de la musique à versailles sur la place
du marché notre dame les groupes
défilent
le commis dont on a gagné un tremplin
qui s'appelle le vendredi du rock
organisé par les jeunes de versailles
donc c'était une super occasion et nous
avait promis qu'on jouerait
à la fête de la musique à versailles et
c'est le cas cette année donc on est
hyper content d'être là ce soir ça nous
permet de partager avec les publics de
partager notre histoire de partager nos
valeurs aussi d'une certaine manière et
c'est vraiment genre en fait c'est un
pur moment c'est un truc qui reste en
nous et peu importe où est ce qu'on va
derrière on comprend et on est super
content déjà d'avoir fait ça ce soir
donc voilà au total six groupes pour des
créneaux de 45 minutes chacun et quand
on s'éloigne de la célèbre place les
ambiances se suivent dans la cité royale
mais ne se ressemblent pas
de telle manière que tout le monde peut
trouver la musique qui lui correspond
chaque année on en profite on se détend
c'est un petit moment de lâcher prise on
profite de des chaleurs et décompresser
après le travail on va faire un tour
voir si à des endroits qui nous plaisent
plus que d'autres s'il ya de la place
incitent à aller boire un verre on verra
en général c'est au feeling mais on va
sûrement peut-être faire un after avec
des amis chez nous finir la soirée en
beauté je pense ouais se balader écoutez
un peu toute la musique qui a qui fait
quoi et rue au restaurant en passant par
les nombreux bars versailles est au
complet jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit et
même bien après
bixente vous avez passé une bonne nuit
c'est vrai qu'il y avait énormément
d'ambiance en tout cas c'était vraiment
apprécié une traditionnelle se dit
derrière c'est vrai mais
la fête de la musique c'est un peu une
tradition ici surtout versailles voit
que les rues sont vraiment innover le
monde rambouillet aussi ce sera ce
week-end le 25 pareil en général il ya
beaucoup de scènes et beaucoup de monde
donc c'est les gens continuent à aimer à
être et c'est parce que c'est un
rendez-vous que tout le monde attend
sénat même si une wii puis s'éteint pas
retour
dgo voilà il y avait bien eu l'effet de
la musique même virtuel tour laisser les
cantons qu'on n'attend plus que de
raison de plus pour venir sortir faire
la fête et écouter de la musique
découvrir de nouveaux artistes et
j'aurais plus et jack lang qui a créé ça
il ya 40 ans 82
et à côté de vous qatar qui est
des missions en cours oui oui du
cartable et genre on va vous présenter
vous êtes artiste donc fini mon teint
vous avez fait de nombreux albums vous
avez vous travaillé depuis longtemps
dans la musique est donc en début
d'émission on doit proposer un défi donc
on avait cinq mois on a donné cinq mots
et vous devez faire un freestyle alors
tête avant de parler du freestyle pas
par la tête de votre nouveau single ou
projet sur paris test vous pouvez nous
en parler en fait là pour l'instant ça
fait ça fait six mois que j'ai pas sorti
et de deux singles ou
de contenus réellement parce que je suis
en train de préparer en fait un retour
en septembre avec énormément de contenu
j'ai des clips de côté des singles
justement de côté j'ai plein de choses
de côté mais en fait là la stratégie
c'est juste de préparer beaucoup pour
pouvoir revenir en septembre avec
beaucoup de contenu du coup c'est un peu
une première une année charnière aussi
pour toi tu as fait tes premiers
concerts oui en fait j'ai vécu un
week-end un peu de folie c'était du
courant décembre
2021 j'ai fait la première partie de
kery james et attrapes j'ai fait mon
premier concert officiel le lendemain à
la salle jacques brel à
montigny-le-bretonneux donc c'était un
gros un gros week-end pour moi ensuite
j'ai sorti un clip qui s'appelle quart
de siècle que j'ai sorti le jour de mes
25 ans et du coup pas ça fait déjà six
mois on est déjà enjoint donc entre
temps j'ai commencé à écrire aussi pour
d'autres personnes j'ai refait un
concert le 10 juin à fontenay le fleury
puis j'ai chanté hier
c'était vraiment c'était génial parce
que j'étais à domicile là je pouvais pas
faire plus agressive où j'étais
dans le quartier de la sourde oreille là
où je vis là où je travaille donc donc
c'est ça a été un bel événement il y
avait beaucoup de monde et du coup
c'était vraiment un plaisir de pouvoir
chanter à la maison puis c'est une
première pardon au forum des arts de
montigny fort hills d'amour dans ce cas
montini voilà il ya le forum de l'arc
qui vient d'ouvrir c'est tout nouveau et
du coup c'est un peu l'inauguration on
va dire cette fête de la musique que ça
s'est très très bien passé c'est
jouissif la scène oui on se rend si on
se lasse pas on sent là ce matin mais
c'est vrai que là je commence par en
plus va enchaîner un but que j'ai
envie de faire toujours plus mais voilà
avec ce qui arrive à la rentrée
ça dépend lierre en fait je finissais le
boulot à 19h et chanter à 19h15 roddick
a commencé j'ai pu quitter cinq minutes
armand j'ai pris ma douche venue elle
résonne 13 on est en train de mettre les
instrus sur l'ordinateur enfin voilà
donc là j'ai même pas eu le temps
d'avoir des pratiques après j'étais
vraiment
la maison donc nous avons beaucoup de
gens que je connaissais devant le
quartier alors que cela dit
non parce que parce que s'il se passe
quoi que ce soit bon c'est pas grave on
enfin je commence à
avoir des ddd morceaux que je connais
très bien du fait que justement j'ai
enchaîne les scènes jeux dessus que de
plus en plus à l'aise donc hier au final
c'était vraiment très fluide par contre
la veille de ma première partie de kery
james ou de mon premier concert c'était
pas pareil
oui voilà en fait j'avais fait un
morceau en novembre 2008 qui avait bien
marché j'étais venu ici d'ailleurs en
parler
donc je suis resté en contact avec kery
james et quand il a su qu'il passe à la
trappe il m'a demandé de faire la
première partie donc c'était c'était
génial sachant que j'étais le seul
artiste à faire sa première partie là
sur sa tournée donc une grande fierté
bien moi
alors avoir un peu du dé ce projet ont
du coup que vous allez nous présenter
c'est possible de te faire un petit
morceau a salué leur petit extrait c'est
un petit grand plaisir alors du coup là
je vais vous interpréter un morceau qui
fait partie de mon premier vrai pc vrai
qu'avant j'ai fait c'était pas vraiment
des albums les plus des ddd ep j'en
avais sortie 3g sorti beaucoup d'oeufs
de morceaux mais j'ai fait un peu le tri
depuis justement mon fameux morceau kery
james on a on va dire que je me suis un
peu professionnalisé et il ya ce fameux
projet qui s'appelle 7 à 8 qui est
toujours disponible partout et là c'est
le seul morceau qui est pas clip et du
projet et c'est pourtant morceau que
j'aime beaucoup donc voilà c'est cela
que vous chantez s'appelle li se nomme
ça ira mieux demain mieux demain - carte
à ses parties locales
moi je vais me lever
bon bah pour moi c'est parti je regarde
on me dit regarde rouge vous regardez si
je peux vous regardez
nous regarde et on ne vous écoute bah
c'est bon je suis prêt moi dépendance
alors est-il en train en régie
c'est parti c'est bon j'attends nikkei
[Musique]
et c'est kurt a en direct de tv 78 c'est
la famille maintenant
ok
un
lavis céder aux débats les deux pieds
dans le vide comme osiris la vie un réel
combat dans lequel tu dois prendre les
risques révolter face à la misère et
l'injustice ce sentiment d'impuissance
quant à deux doigts du précipice
imprévisible comme ce foutu corona on
n'oublie pas toutes ces victimes celle
des guerres des attentats pour qu'il
arrive aux n'auront toujours ceux qui
sont partis trop tôt
mais à leurs rames la vie cdo des bases
par dans les plus grand coster c'est
souvent lors d'un débat que tombent les
masques des imposteurs affligé face à
toutes ces personnes son coeur dur de
réagir face à tous ces rires moqueurs
cruauté humaine à part bar un sens c'est
dur de perdre sa vie en rose en fonction
des banques c'est seul sur talence et
franchit les obstacles en restant sont
c'est forcément des obstacles lors d'une
ascension et ma belle
ça ira mieux demain on vit dans un monde
tellement cru
mais ça tu ne peux rien c'est jeter
leurs ressaisis toi
ça ira mieux demain s'est jetée là et
croire en toi
tout est lié au destin combien de fonds
a déçu combien de ventes a menti ceux
qui se prétendent et fidèles sont les
premiers kits ont trahi combien de fanta
déçu combien de fois on t'a fait du mal
en un acte tu peux perdre confiance
sentiment si brutale en un acte tout
peut basculer non tu préfères marché
celle qui t'a faire bousculer plus
jamais reculer contradictoires mais toi
aussi tu as déjà blessé c'est trop tard
pour le pardon quand sonne l'heure du
décès très souvent dans l'excès l'humain
peut-être texan combien de fontain vexé
mais tu est rester dans le silence
combien de fois tu as rêvé de vivre dans
un monde sans violence pourtant si
passionné par ces séries ou les intenses
en pleine souffrance d'un futur rime
avec incertitude plus nombreux sont les
tout à chaque prise d'altitude une chose
est sûre c'est chacun son tour je n'ai
vu je les ai vécus quoi qu'il arrive la
roue tourne
ma belle
ça ira mieux demain on vit dans un monde
tellement cruel mais ça tu n'y peut rien
sèche de l'homme ressaisis toi
ça ira mieux demain s'est jetée nord et
croire en toi
tout est lié au destin la vie c'est des
mots la vie ces débats s'est jetée là
mon frère homo de la hooters girl la vie
c'était beau la visée débat tu l'aimé
plus que tout on avait pourtant mignon
garde verda proches aux ruptures
amoureuses
que c'est dur de s'en remettre que rien
dans les poches une relation douteux
qu'une envie disparaître accédants des
illusions sont si imprévisible maladie
ou trahison
aucun est invincible mais
babel
ça ira mieux demain on vit dans un monde
tellement cru
mais ça tu n'y peut rien sèche de larmes
ressaisis toi
ça ira mieux demain s'est jetée l'homme
et croit en toi
tout est lié au destin malgré les toutes
les déceptions ça ira mieux de ma vie
malgré les coups les désillusions
ont malgré les belles et toutes les
tempêtes
présente sur ton chemin je veux que ce
rêve où résonnent dans ta tête
ça ira mieux demain
[Musique]
merci merci
juste pour pas un petit peu le thème de
cette fois mais en fait tendance passe
bas cc c'est vrai que généralement dans
mes textes ce que je prône contrairement
c'est vrai peut-être à certains rappeurs
c'est avec le moral peut faire peur
encore un peu mais mais il ya plein de
deux rappeurs que j'écrive très bien et
puis moi j'ai toujours eu justement une
attache à l'écriture et je prône
vraiment
le partage l'amour je suis aussi
quelqu'un qui dénonce parce que des
choses qui comme nous tous ches panses
clé qui me révolte voilà chacun ses
valeurs ses principes mais forcément on
peut être heurtée par certaines choses
surtout dans le monde dans lequel on vit
mais j'ai toujours cette petite note
d'espoir que j'ai toujours eu et ce
morceau c'est vraiment en fait c'est
vraiment pénible ne respecte
pas ce que j'écris parce que voilà c'est
c'est bien il peut être un peu négatif
d'avoir exactement parce que on est tous
dits froids on est tous amenés à vivre
les choses durent là je parle de décès
je parle de rupture je parlais des
choses très dures du du corona de voilà
je parle de toutes ces choses là mais
bien mais faut se relever il faut
toujours se dire que ça ira mieux demain
on va passer maintenant au deuxième
t'as tendu après votre chanson le défi
alors il rappeler les mots alors on pas
purgé alors il y avait 72 8 jours
cueillette bonjour ils sont partis
l'arctique et
voilà donc c'était les impôts et donc
village et en
plus il le fait sans me regarder
il devient à peu près mais s'ils
prenaient un café
découle non plus les dix souffrent
déjà je vais voir si ça vous plaît mais
ton corps car oui j'ai pris c'est moi et
je les ai fait dans l'ordre vous menez
avait
donc c'est parti
mais ce drame enchanté aujourd'hui le
défi je relève cinq mots quelques
minutes c'est vrai que ça va vite à
l'école je lave où je n'étais pas très
bon élève mais maman est fier je rempli
des salles je passe sur tv 78 il me
reste encore beaucoup d'objectifs sur la
liste je me dois d'épater la france
faire parler les journalistes animateurs
entraîneurs directeurs rappeur pas trop
le temps pour la fête j'écris des textes
je mange tout j'aime pas trop laissé les
miettes ses amours époux et épais pardon
pousserait en forêt j'irai plus souvent
à la cueillette le temps file je
continue d'écrire c'est pas du gâteau et
je passe un grand bonjour à tous les
petits artistes j'ai apporté un peu de
chaleur chaleur sur ce beau plateau
désolé pas de place pour les ours
polaires ou les loups arctiques du coup
pour celles et ceux qui ne me
connaissent pas un moment écartée
j'avance petit à petit pour faire partie
des grands ce rap c'est pour tout le
monde ta maman tous cousins tata tahir
personne ne me connaissait demain on
entendra jusqu'à le tartre godrans
bon le défi relevé mais si désiré
surtout les 60
justement texte
c'est vrai qu'on va dire que le si je
peux dire que j'ai un petit talent entre
c'est l'écriture c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'aime énormément faire est
quelque chose qui va vite après tout
dépend le le thème abordé et puis ça
m'arrive aussi j'aime bien prendre du
temps là c'est plus le côté un peu frais
jeune fille je mets sur mes morceaux ça
va vite mais j'aime aussi prendre le
temps de texte mais j'ai plusieurs
façons d'écrire enfin ça va très vite et
bim da cruz des avions gros studios
parfois ça prend plusieurs semaines
parce que l'ado l'histoire d'un sursaut
d'orgueil des libyens sur le terrain
cinq minutes exactement et l'autre ont
été détournés firmi désolé ça fait c'est
le principal
merci à tous sa
carrière merci merci et chanté l'hymne
ainsi courtois et puis on se retrouve
très vite ni pour une nouvelle émission
j'aimerais bien la fête des loges
[Rires]
merci à tous a très vite
[Musique]